もしもしリクオ?
キャッサバは買ったか?
準備ができた?
わかった
オッケーだ
うわっ
なんだよ
ちっ
うわっ
おい!
今すぐ集合だ
くっそ
来たな
お前らよく来てくれた。
隊長、どうしたでありますか?
外を見てみろ
謎の宇宙船がこの星を攻めてきている。
俺たちは
この星を守らなければいけない。
隊長。何か作戦は?
ある。
それは一体?
これは!?
下敷きを100枚準備した。
宇宙船からの攻撃から地球を守るためには
強力なバリアが必要になる。
文房具からの鋭利な攻撃をものともしない
下敷きを100枚合体させると
この地球至上で最大の防御力になるであろう。
必ず我々でこのバリアを完成させるのだ。
ついに完成した
俺たちの
バリアが!
下敷き100枚を使って最強のバリアは完成したが、
大事なのは強度の問題だ。
これからいくつかの検証を行って
このバリアが本当に宇宙船に有効かどうかを確かめていこうと思う。
お前らイイか?!
おい!
最強のバリア、最初の検証はカラーボールを100個当ててみようと思う。
いくぞ!
おい!
なんかバラバラなんだよねw
ふふふ
果たしてこの最強のバリアはカラーボールに耐えることができるのか?
はくしゅうん
早速やってみようと思う!
来い!
やった～!!!
次はこちらを使う
エアーガンだ
というわけで早速検証スタートだ
やった～!!!
まただ～!!!
最後の検証は、バリアに人が乗っかるとどうなるか
うわっ
バリアは壊れてないから…
成功!
イェーーーイ!!!
はっ
おい!
宇宙船だ!
きゃ～～!!!
はっ!?
待てよお前ら!
うわっ
あ…
ああ?!
なん…なんで浮いてるの…?
えっ
なんで…
うぇ～～～
はい。というわけでいかがだったでしょうか?
インデペンデンス・デイ　リサージェンス
7月9日、土曜日から全国で上映されます
で!
映画の内容なんですけども、
宇宙船が地球にやってくるんですけど、
その宇宙船がめっちゃくっちゃでかいんですよ
アメリカ大陸を包み込むぐらいの超巨大な宇宙船が来て
地球に何をしてくるのやら
という内容になっております!
今みなさん映像の方見ていただいたと思うんですけども、
すっごい迫力でございます。
そしてクオリティが高い!!
もうなんか地球がめちゃくちゃになるようなシーンとかもあったので、
スッゲーそこらへんがリアルで僕はもうビックリしながらみていました。
果たして!
地球はどうなるのでしょうか!!!
僕もめちゃくちゃ楽しみでございます!
というわけで!インデペンデンス・デイ　リサージェンス　是非みなさん見てください!!
じゃあな!
リクオか?
ああ
キャッサバの準備はできたか?
ああわかった
そうだな。今すぐ持ってきてくれ
頼んだぞ…
おい!
集合だ!